Hey guys welcome back. I'm Nate
And thank you for joining us today on The King Of Random. A bullwhip is a staple tool of cowboys and movie action stars alike.
Most bull whips are made from kangaroo leather and are carefully braided. They can take quite a while to make and cost quite a bit of money.
The purpose of today's video is to learn how to make a bullwhip yourself in a lot less time and for a way lower cost.
Here's the materials
we'll need to make our bullwhip. A piece of 3/4 inch PVC a piece of 1-inch PVC, some paracord, some bb's,
Athletic tape, electrical tape, and a drill bit. With all the materials assembled,
let's start by making our handle.The first step is to cut your 3/4 inch PVC the length that you want your handle.
I'm going to cut mine to be 9 inches long. We also want a 1 inch long piece of our 1 inch PVC.
With the two pieces cut, press the small piece all the way onto the longer piece.
Now that we have our basic handle assembled, it's time to start measuring and cutting our paracord.
Our goal today is to make an 8-foot bullwhip.
So we're gonna take a length of paracord.Run it through the handle and measure it so that it's 8 feet in front of the
handle and about 2 feet behind.
Four feet.
Four feet again.
We now have one length of paracord.
That's between 10 and 11 feet long. With the paracord will now measure off nine more pieces of
diminishing lengths so that our bullwhip will be tapered from the handle to the thinnest part at the end of the whip.
I'll use a piece of electrical tape to mark off where the bottom of the handle is on our first piece of paracord
the first piece of paracord we cut will run the entire length of the whip and the last 18 inches of it will be what's
Called the fall of the whip this is a very thin part that helps give it that distinctive crack that whips are known for
Another piece of electrical tape measures the beginning of the fall our second piece of paracord should run the length from the first tape mark to
the second
For the remaining pieces of paracord we need to cut let's take off eight inches of length for each cord for example the second cord
We cut was just over seven feet long
We'll take ake that measurement and take off eight inches from it and that will be the size of the next piece of paracord
I now have all ten pieces of my paracord cut out in diminishing lengths
Don't be too worried about having it be
Exactly eight inches shorter every time if you're off by an inch or two here or there
It's not really gonna make a difference now
We do need to cut three more pieces of paracord traditional bull whips are made from leather often kangaroo leather because it's the strongest kind
However leather is a lot more dense and heavy than
Paracord so what we need to do is add something that gives our bullwhip a lot more weight
Let's cut three more lengths of our paracord matching lengths to three of our existing pieces
I'm going to cut one length that matches our third longest piece
Then come in three pieces and match that one and then come in three more pieces and match that one
With each of those three matching pieces of paracord that we just cut what we want to do is pull out the internal
Strands from the paracord completely the strings that were on the inside of the paracord are garbage for this project you can throw it away
With the internal strands removed we want to seal off one end of each of our cords with paracord the best way to do that
Is to melt them closed?
Now what we're going to do with these three strands is fill them entirely with bb's this will give some good
Flexible weight to our whip to make it easier to fit the bb's into our paracord
I'm going to use the back of this drill bit to open up the unmelted end of our paracord
You need to make sure that you're using a drill bit a little bit larger than the diameter of a BB
I'm using a
3/16 inch drill bit fit the shaft of the drill bit into the opening of the paracord
Now to make this permanent
We're going to melt the end of the paracord while it's on the drill bit and then once it's cooled. We'll pull it off
With our three lengths of empty paracord fused on one end and melted open on the other end
It's time to start filling them with bb's
With the mouth of the paracord melted open the bb's easily drop in you then need to force the bb's usually one at a time
From the mouth all the way back to the tail end
It can be fairly time-consuming filling up all three of these strands with bb's, but have some patience and keep at it
And it'll be full before you know it
With the first one done now you fill the other two of the same way
There you go all three strands filled completely with BB's these things have a really good weight to them
But they are still extremely flexible now. Let's just melt the ends so that the bb's can't fall out
Gather up the ends of your 12 shorter pieces and line them up with the tape mark on the first piece that you cut using
Electrical tape tightly secure all 13 strands of paracord together
Now starting about
3/4 of an inch away from the end of your handle drill a hole using the same drill bit you used on the paracord
We now want to take the extra piece of
Paracord from the first piece that we cut pass it down through the handle and then through the hole
We just drilled you might find it helpful to melt the end of the paracord
Pull that strand tight until it pulls the rest of the cords down into the handle with it
Take the remaining end and wrap it around the bottom of your handle as tight as you can
Run the excess cord back inside the handle and use a piece of electrical tape to hold it in place
Quick update we have now cut several lengths of paracord to make our whip the longest one will extend about 8 feet beyond the end
of the handle and there are nine more pieces of
Diminishing lengths getting smaller and smaller to give our whip a nice taper
We then added three more lengths of paracord
Which we took the insides out and filled them up with bb's sealing off both ends by melting them
We've bundled all the different strands of paracord together tape them at the end and fit them inside the handle at this point the only
Step left is to use our electrical tape and our athletic tape to bind the whole thing together
Let's start by securing all of the different pieces of paracord at the top of the handle
As you can see I am not skimping out with the electrical tape
I'm making sure that there is a lot of connection between the handle and the strands of paracord now
I'll take some electrical tape and about every foot and a half
I'll wrap tightly around all of the strands of paracord this will help them prevent getting twisted when we apply our athletic tape
With our strands now attached to our handle
Let's take the athletic tape and starting at the base of the handle wrap it around all the way until we reach the fall of
The whip athletic tape is great for this because it's made of cloth
And it's very thin so it's extremely flexible and it's not so sticky that when you're using the whip the sticky bits will grip to
Each other and get all gummed up
It's important to try and keep your
Strands all pulled tight and parallel as you wrap them with tape you don't want them to be twisting or you could have trouble using
your whip later
There you have it now that the whip is all wrapped up in the athletic tape it is finished and ready to use but first
Let's decorate it
Tape and rubber gloves do not really mix very well
There we have it our whip is complete and decorated, so now let's go test it out all right
Let's try out the whip for precaution
I am wearing a long sleeve jacket, and I'll be using my glasses as well the first thing. I'm going to try is something
That's called the Cattleman's crack
That worked very well that was a good crack, let's try that again. I'm gonna face a little bit more toward the camera
Boom that's awesome alright, I've got another one gonna try this is called the overhead crack
That went I love it that one just looks so stylish doing it I think I
Hope I look good. Maybe I look like a dork and now I'm gonna try something
I don't know the name of this
But I kind of just discovered that it works while experimenting with a whip and so I'm gonna try this too.
I like that one. I like all of them
They're fun for just a second
Let's talk about what is happening here when I whip the whip in those special ways it gets a bit of a curl in it
And when that happens it starts moving faster
And faster and faster as it gets down to the end and then this part which is called the fall
Ends up rotating in a circle so fast that it breaks the sound barrier
so the crack of a whip is actually a sonic boom when this thing goes as much as
750 miles an hour
That's amazing it is believed that a whip is the first man-made object to ever break the sound barrier
Let's try this a couple more times
Now one thing left I want to try is I want to see what happens if this whip starts hitting some stuff
I'm gonna do some tests trying to whip a sheet of styrofoam to see what the effect is
I'm gonna start off pretty gentle to try and get a hang of aiming at the styrofoam
Okay that hit it
It might be hard to see but that actually put a dent in the styrofoam already try hitting a little harder, ooh
That is a significant dent right there big old line drawn right into the styrofoam
I'll see if I can really add some power and get it to crack and hit the board oh
That hit it took a chunk out of it there you go this styrofoam does have a
protective plastic layer kind of holding it all together and
So it might be even more impressive that it's been able to market this much, but that took a chunk right out of the top
That's exciting
Holy cow that one was like extra loud for some reason that made my ears ring
Wow and look at the market left this is nuts. I'm just gonna see if I can take out a small bit of branch
Using the whip try and hit in that area can't aim well enough to be more precise than that
Ha nailed it
Bull's eye sniff it clean off
there you go that is how you can take paracord PVC some bb's and a little bit of tape and make yourself a
functioning bullwhip this thing is quite fun and
surprisingly easy to get it to crack it didn't take much practice before I could get it to crack every time a
Special shout-out to our friend Garrett who suggested and showed us how to make this kind of whip Thank You Garrett
Remember if you do make this whip always use
Precautions wear long sleeves wear protective eye gear and make sure there's no one else around you that you could possibly hurt or anything that
You could destroy thanks for joining us for this project and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
Leave splosions
Hey guys. I hope you're feeling happy today
I know I am because you're keeping this channel alive and well we really appreciate your support because we could not be doing this without
You that's why you're the best